voici le souk hôtel en 1963 dans une
couleur beige kaki et le voici dans les
années soixante dix orange ce téléphone
est symptomatique d'une époque celle des
années 60-70 que l'on appelle les années
pop un engouement particulier pour cette
couleur vive dans tous les domaines du
quotidien elle est mise à l'honneur dans
une exposition au musée de la villa
saint quentin en yvelines
moulin à café celui qui est présenté en
blanc date de 1956 est l'un des premiers
moulins à café motorisée de chez
moulinex et
voilà la fin des années 60 début des
années soixante dix le même moulin à
café sera colorée en orange pour
s'adapter à la fois aux goûts du public
des nombreuses marques et décline donc
l'art objets en orange diverses
explications permettent de comprendre le
groupe pour cette couleur évidemment un
phénomène culturel qui est d'autant plus
remarquable qu'il apparaît à peu près
partout dans le monde enfin du moins
dans l'hémisphère nord et sans doute
parce que cette couleur orange avait
plusieurs plusieurs vertus monde une
part elle était relativement inédite
c'était également une couleur qui
qui avait quelque chose de relativement
dynamique
de joyeux extrêmement voyante l'oranje
se développe aussi dans le domaine de la
sécurité elle apparaîtra même si on les
tgv dans les années 80 le goût pour le
orange commence à se terminer mais le
tgv forcément été conçu plusieurs années
auparavant et le range tgv a été validée
dès 1977 on était là au coeur de la
période où on cherchait à la fois une
couleur qui soit à la sncf qui soit à la
fois innovante originale mais qui
s'inscrivent aussi dans bull époque des
fauteuils un plateau une table basse en
passant par les vêtements le musée de la
ville possède une collection de design
très importante cette exposition intègre
également quelques prêts d'oeuvres d'art
notamment une extension de césar de 1969
qui proviennent du musée d'art
contemporain du val de marne
[Musique]